So color is a psychological phenomenon,
all right.
You know what In fact let me go back to,
to something here.
If I turn on a red light and
a green light and
I blend them together
what color will I see.
>> Yellow.
>> Yellow, right.
So why?
When I tell people this at Georgia Tech,
some of them tell me,
oh well, you know,
red is here in the spectrum.
And green is here in the spectrum.
And when you turn on both of them
you get the average spectrum.
No.
[LAUGH]
The light doesn't know
anything about averaging.
So here's a green light,
and here is a red light.
What happens is this light
over here in the green,
triggers the green cones a little
bit more than the red cones.
And the red light makes the red cones go
a little bit more than the green cones.
Kay, so let's pretend for
a moment they were sort of balanced.
So in other words,
if I had a yellow light,
which makes both of the cones
go about the same amount.
Your system can't tell the difference
between a green light and
a red light turned on
versus a yellow light.
Forget this little blue stuff here for
now, all right?
So the reason that red plus green make
yellow with lights has nothing to do
with physics and everything to do
with how your retina is put together.
Right?
The red and
green cones go on at the same time.
So, color is psychological.
That is you can think of
color as representative.
Some combination,
linear combination otherwise of red,
green and blue and
it's related to cones not to physics.
By the way almost all of
us have the same cones, but
there are some people who don't.
Right, so the sky might not really look
blue to them although actually to them
it looks blue, but
it's actually not blue because
they actually can't see blue.
So these people are referred
to as color blind,
all right, a bunch of people
are missing one type of cone.
Almost all of them, by the way, are men.
It, it's, it's some reasonable
percentage of men are colorblind.
Some tiny,
tiny percentage of women are colorblind.
So it was kind of funny back when I
was a grad student, psychology class,
people have to sometimes do a,
so I was the TA,
people would have to do an experiment
and write it up and hand it in.
And you can tell, every now and
then, when somebody, shall we say,
ran out of time to actually
do a real experiment.
because they'd say they worked
with 20 color-blind patients,
ten men, ten women.
For them to find ten color-blind women,
they probably would have had to
sample more than Massachusetts.
So there are very few color-blind women.